[Music]
and got scammed news I love that
submitted by the shermanator sound
cooled from UV that sounds like some
[ __ ] dweeb that is about to get the
[ __ ] for the first time ever he's like
you ready for the shermanator she's like
no I'm [ __ ] out of here I'm out with
that American Pires it sounds like an
American American Pie it sounds like a
good way to make the name sure man a
little more confident
I didn't say cool I said confident yeah
Sherman it sounds like mclovin I know I
should yeah yeah yeah yeah what would
you name your kid Sherman do you hate
him fraudulent advertising scheme stole
millions but no one wants to own up to
it
okay which one is this one well they
like investors or customers so this is a
massive ad fraud scheme in America's
edie fraud scheme yeah advertising
advertisements frauds maybe could be for
like do you have a limp dick so it could
be something embarrassing that no one
wants to be like damn yeah I got duped
advertising fraud see I'm trying to
figure out where the noun is okay so
what happened here is that there was
this scheme that involved fraud with
that website so let me actually
exclaiming wait clarified okay all right
so Google has acknowledged that this
scheme stole close to ten million
dollars from its ad networks and
partners and it's been shut down and so
this was linked to more than 30
companies that apparently like they
unwittingly helped the these fraudsters
to earn money so what was happening is
that they were buying these apps and
this is mainly for Android apps this is
what happened with Android app it was
about a hundred and John Gio don't it
was a hundred and twenty five Android
apps and websites and what they were
doing is that they were tracking like
when you use that app that these like
shell companies but when you use these
apps they would track the real of human
users and they would use that data to
program BOTS to mimic their behavior so
they can evade fraud detection
system oh wow like real people are
actually viewing these have some
next-level [ __ ] when it was a long spit
yeah and they're saying that that ten
million it's like not even a fraction of
how much they really just ten million
confirmed yeah dude that's amazing
clicks with that [ __ ] it's so weird the
Instagram has been cracking me the [ __ ]
up because they've been giving me
they've been pushing like these ads for
four game apps like on your phone right
I saw the funniest [ __ ] game ever
dude even so little you have two [ __ ]
pictures side by side and you're trying
to see you're trying to catch the
cheater like the person who's getting
cheated on right and so you see like a
hair you pick out the hair that's not
supposed to be there are you Seri win
the game the wife gets beat up are you
serious
looks like a better guess who the wife
it's like a picture the wife has a black
eye had a missing tooth sponsored
Instagram pose
it's a sponsored post based on what you
look at all my stuff that sponsored is
it's all related to like clothes or well
the thing I get is its clothing and boy
tie my gadget you search for clothing in
my time yeah like all my like some of
the like related videos because I
watched so much stuff it's all
kickboxing fighting and then clothing
you know mine is completely different
than what I watch
oh really yeah mine keeps promoting
these same cargo shorts over and over
know I click on and lift a truck
do you wear cargo shorts I don't think
so maybe is it like you do like tactical
[ __ ] yeah no but it's like Street it's
like street wear cargo shorts [ __ ] it's
not tactical garvey we're-- stuff it
might be suggest 100 Zealanders oh yeah
maybe oh I get a lot of fishing gear
stuff and I'm like I have nothing I
think they just recognize your face yep
I like you looks like a [ __ ] sushi
yeah because like I'm looking at bar
and like from my top down if I were to
like finish your outfit I would put
cargo shorts there that might be why
you're getting suggested and then you
unit yeah fishing rod you can see tackle
and a fishing pole here and maybe your
fly-fishing bro laters Oh fly them is
what I look like I guess there's no you
look like the guy that will get cheated
on okay that makes sense yeah well
that's that's actually what the thing is
so the guy no the guy is cheating on the
girl and the and you're playing a Latham
why is the girl Getti well you're
playing well the girl is beating up the
girl first of all the app I thought the
guy beat the [ __ ] out of the girl and it
made me laugh because of how
ridiculously yeah like hula [ __ ] why
would it Instagram put they say my shits
too like touchy right I'm like how the
[ __ ] do you promote this game but I
really looked at the app and the hand
that's picking out the hair is a girl
lady's hand you explained it really well
yeah you duped us well when you say wife
and beat in the same sentence then we
all think I'm picturing a game where you
throw your wife down the stairs and you
try to give them as many stairs as you
can and it lights up like a slot machine
Bing Bing if you want observe it like
you wouldn't have been able to tell that
that was a lady's hands because there
was no like nail polish or anything on
it you just have to look it was like oh
it looks like a female's hand but there
wasn't a nail polisher maybe he doesn't
let her get her nails painted oh my god
basically the wife beat the [ __ ] out of
the girl that was [ __ ] her husband
and that's the only game go after the
dude so the lady like I think the image
of the [ __ ] missing teeth and the
black guy was ridiculous though that is
wild yeah like I didn't download it a
lot of Panama
you did not out of morals I want it too
yeah
it sounds fun now you promoted it know
everyone's looking it up yes your will
right I am getting paid for them I don't
know all I know is that like all this
stuff it kind of knows what we
and I don't know what or what website we
said yes that you can track all mine but
I don't know which one it is because
like on with every app it but like
everything's connected one time me and
you we were texting each other in
Spanish and then she sends me a
screenshot of an ad that she was like on
a website something it was all in
Spanish yeah I was like what the [ __ ] I
think what if it's an Apple agreement
like every time the phone don't when you
sign up for an app you know there's a
bunch of [ __ ] that no one reads and
you go I accept I think it's not it's in
there somewhere and it's like Apple is
allowed to track all of your yeah cuz
everything I look up on my computer I
get an Instagram app for so if I'm
looking up like I don't know something
like new cars or whatever yeah my shits
connected [ __ ] I don't look up
fishing at all
oh we just now getting well people just
so into the whole internet thing that
like oh god it's happening again
[ __ ] the fishy should probably I don't
know oh my god did you say the word
fishing because I might yeah they say
some [ __ ] I think we were wrong Casey he
was talking about his eczema and then I
started getting ads for eczema cream and
I'm like I would never look for that
sighs okay I was with Casey and here we
were talking about how he has a really
itchy butt hole
[Laughter]
talking about it all the time he just
got sponsored if I get a [ __ ] but
it's cream on my father coming here I'll
[ __ ] screenshot it like speed one
from watching this video and you got a
serine X to you or you got a [ __ ]
name I turn that [ __ ] off oh oh I use
Siri all the time and Google home I use
go home but I don't like Google home is
mine yeah we're so behind we don't have
a Google home you have Alexa no if you
replace all your light bulbs in your
house with that [ __ ] dude right when you
walk yeah yeah Alexa oh yeah [ __ ] 50%
like Oh 50% dude that's how they turn
the lights on in the kitchen
I trained my dogs to do that [ __ ] bro
we're really not careful with internet
stuff though cuz can I just say because
in the past year I've had my credit card
numbers stolen twice I had somebody try
to file taxes under my name is your
legal name Bose yeah dog oh sure what's
your is it really and my legal dope ass
me it's my last name and your last name
is my headphones what Bozeman it's not
even your name is Bose Bozeman Bose
you're like a 1960s superhero like that
sounds like one of those silver I don't
question it okay you know if they just
bleep out the first name each time just
like your name is beep Bose that's
[ __ ] hilarious dude I get why people
would ID fraud you though cuz like I
don't know what what Bose Bozeman looks
like it yeah and they might have a lot
of money and they just want to check it
out they're like let's see what this is
yeah because your name sounds artsy as
[ __ ] but how did they filed my taxes
before me yeah you had to get your
refund that's a common yeah dude
how do you even do that though that's
terrible but honestly I think it's cuz I
do so much stuff online and that stuff
is just not it's secured like they're
gonna like use this is f do this huge
shirt is it you need a VPN and you need
to follow my catches is like well you
could pay for them too because I don't
get a check back
get it back in there like about you that
you please follow my glasses you're
gonna pay 60 grand dude no that's what
they did they filed for it and then
didn't they didn't follow up because
owed money yeah you didn't open that man
like oh I gotta go letter came on a red
piece of paper and it's like we're view
but we've been waiting for you feel like
there you are Oh stupid they [ __ ] up
this yeah
[Music]